so question seven i hope i can read this
uh enjoying linkedin
uh i'm enjoying link someone's right
saying i'm enjoying link i'm learning
french and german right where can i
when can i start reading books of
interest
okay well
again
i find that until i'm very good i prefer
to read on link
because i don't like if on a page
there's like 10 or 15 words that i don't
know that's a problem it starts to
interfere with the dictionary
now if the subject
is something that i'm very familiar with
they're very interested in like history
you can actually have a lot of words
that you don't understand but if you're
reading literature i find that you miss
those words you're missing a lot so i
tend to want to find say things that
were written in the 19th century you
know older material that i can get free
and import into link
how long does it take to get to a level
where you can just pick up a novel and
read it it takes a long time i can't say
it just depends but it takes a long time
but i would try it i would buy a book
buy a book on something you're very
interested in and try it
personally i fully agree anything and
one thing i don't do is i don't then
look up every word and try and import it
into link i did that for a while but
it's just too time consuming and the
benefits are limited i guess it's nice
to just you know try to either guest
content or just if you understand 90 of
the words you can already
simply
absolutely and and what's so great about
language learning is you want to be
doing different things so read a book
that you don't understand do some very
simple content pull something of
interest into link and link it do all
these different things as long as you're
engaging with the language you're going
to improve
right i think that i think that's that's
quite fantastic and that's what i
started uploading some uh
russian content into link actually right
because i i had this lady actually do
the audio for me as well so i'm really
excited about that because then i can
see i can study the words i can take a
look at them right um i can do a
i can do flash cards
which is awesome and that's been
boosting my learning and my
understanding which is a lot of fun
next question how are you enjoying
polish and how
um are you finding i guess constant
constant clusters well i'm enjoying
polish immensely and i enjoy the the
real polish from filter but i'm also
enjoying now i bought
an audiobook
cervoni alet which is this book about
russia which i've read in english and
i've now listened i'm listening to the
audiobook i also found an audiobook on
polish history i've ordered some polish
books from a canadian web-based
bookstore i'm having some trouble down
they won't let you download ebooks from
poland for some reason but anyway i'm
enjoying it tremendously the um and of
course helped by my knowledge of other
slavic languages uh and so far as
consonant clusters i mean it's really
not it seems that the poles they will go
s z c z
for something that uh maybe in russian
it would be you know sure like it's not
a problem you just get used to it i i
really just looks intimidating right it
looks like oh my god
all these consonants but i mean how can
you have a word that goes s s z season
come on
but i mean i shouldn't say that because
every how can you have english where you
know the word through for instance
cough rough
they're that's very weird so to that
extent polish is consistent
polish is consistent
the only one that isn't consistent i
discovered is
the word for apple which is yeah bulk is
not pronounced yellow it's called
pronoun
so there are some sounds that disappear
in publish
anyway
that's interesting i'm not like i'm
actually i'm legitimately interested in
picking it up like we're getting started
within the next
few months right so we're going to see
your results i mean it's a great country
there's 40 million people they've got a
great i have a lot of friends
basically here in vancouver that are
they have polish background right and uh
and one of the best friends who actually
went to med school in poland then he
came back and uh he speaks with his
parents and uh i know a few words but
like i i found uh something's
tremendously tremendously hard actually
like the the l sound with the you know
the song it sounds like a w yeah and
then i was saying i was trying to say
the word uh benjish and then my friend
said it sounds like you're saying the
word for belgium so okay
so don't worry
i'll have to to to
focus on pronunciation for polish for
sure and i think that the last question
here is actually uh i'm interested in
hearing the answer for myself but
it's a it's a good question
uh what
kind of advice uh or what advice would
you give to your younger self in terms
of language learning um yes language
learning you know
it's an interesting question because
really when i read the book that i wrote
10 years ago about language learning
nothing much has changed
technology has changed access to you
know
conversation partners on the internet
content on the internet uh minidisc
became mp3 player
uh you know 50 years ago i had open reel
tape recorders
um
no once once i got
once i realized that to learn language
you have to be motivated
and it's not sufficient to sit in the
classroom because that was my experience
in school
where the teacher would teach us french
and we would pass the exam we couldn't
speak
once i realized that it was all about
motivation and spending the time
and really engaging with the language
then that's it i explore i support for
content i i you know focus on structures
that give me trouble
nothing much different
okay
so that the the um
that closes it would you like to add
anything no i just want to say we went a
little bit longer today because we were
fortunate to have uh gabriella gabriel
visit with us huge pleasure and provide
his input and i've done some videos with
him for his facebook page and
hopefully we'll do some more of course
with a great pleasure so it was fun to
read the questions
and uh thank you steve thank you gabriel
bye for now